welcome to this video playing a linen
steel leading shine this is hunter grass
roll alright so a sloth now let's play
with queen bee three Quincy to us very
similar now g3 yeah this is some fairly
solid way for white to play often
leading to positions that are related
more to them to the Catalan opening then
the sloth with the bishop on g2 so let's
see Knight c3 looks like normal good
good play uh-huh so is going 45 hmm
yeah I could just take it too or is this
yeah this is simple the question is
should i play 94 now i should I take
let's play that it's a bit more more
ambitious
wyd said DN disposition is to to gain
space and push black Becky in the center
I've got an extra bone in the center and
I just don't push this alright so he
doesn't really have a square foot for
the night is already yeah he must
sacrifice a piece now otherwise the
night has no square the question is how
to to play that now for me to really win
because the position should be winning
and already at least them it seems that
I should I should win apiece but how is
it what's the exact way to to play
Bishop e3 night xe5 de 525 mmm it's not
entirely clear
here
maybe just get out of this
so we intends to keep the peace with 97
now maybe Bishop e3 was better to know
how to tell
mmm can very strange put the excellent
for what now this is not nothing special
I mean okay white white is better when
it's not now when every authority was
close to exploding maybe we should be
three or some some tactical some
technical thing okay yeah let's try to
undermine this provoking for us the
weakness on a five and now we're taking
it
hmm how to proceed it's not
that's a plan
trying to double on the default
all right it's just a tech a five
hmm you didn't didn't look at that might
be five hmm probably not helping much
all right
it's still on
still some compensation
check
yeah it's a of course becoming a
crapshoot now with this little time on
the clock some play against f7 and the
pawns probably it's not enough for white
but so it's not super clear I don't
really understand what is doing anyway
threatening a bunch of discoveries now
check
time warning
check
you threaten me droopy one made
v6 e6 was the move okay but maybe I can
still get this in you cannot take
because of rook h7 made
and what the Jeep on this one g6 check
need to play for me TM check check
check
she's chan late check check yeah
unfortunately I couldn't couldn't manage
a mate and this means chat in english
the skin check white forfeits on time
yeah okay so check check check me changa
did I don't think check check yeah it's
it's just just no chick mid actually
setting this mate Oh g7 oh yeah check
check yeah geez having check book to
check and mate yeah this would have been
nice yeah we're very very unclear this I
mean okay yeah this is I think pretty
clearly winning for white IAM it is this
kind of configuration is hardly bearable
and gap I don't know what's about what
what's going on before I mean I had an
excellent position right of the opening
and somehow screwed this up and here it
was just a wild fight how to hard to say
what was going on he had this kind of
position yeah it's okay i'm not so i'm
pretty nicely coordinated it's not I e5
would have been good if I have food good
must go here and then group here this
good now
this kind of position is quite nice
because before has such a big threat
okay but I didn't have any time in to
check appreciate that but I think it was
wasn't so bad what I did crashing
through on a seven check and Avantia why
does some white is excellent check yeah
it is pretty pretty weird too long i def
93 is really weird move why would you go
in to get into this into this kind of
configuration which which is very
clearly lost I mean it's just this
threat and you're basically dead here
okay look h7 made they needed to to see
this to see this this mate check check
yeah here's a forcemeat on another
computer sees it but ok with little time
yeah ok an interesting game thanks